by joining us now is former national
justice director for Bernie Sanders
Tesla Vergara was with us Fox News legal
analyst Gregg Jarrett former Clinton
pollster Fox News contributor Doug Schon
Teslin I guess I got to start with you
tonight I know you were big Bernie
supporter and if I supported Bernie
Sanders and I found out the news that we
just discovered yesterday that the fix
was in that the primary was rigged that
she stole the election that a signed
secret deal was made with the Clinton
campaign in the DNC I would be
apoplectic and how shocking this could
happen in the United States of America
in this day and age it's not even it's
bigger than just being a supporter you
know I'm here for every supporter every
surrogate that was dragged all over
Twitter for speaking the truth like
senator Nina Turner dr. Cornel West
every voter that voted in this in this
primary those who really believed in the
American process all of us from Sanders
staffers supporters surrogates have all
come to say we told you so and it's so
much bigger shine than just a politician
are being a pundit I worked on the
campaign I spent seven eight months on
the campaign every day away from my ten
year old child lost my mother while I
was on this campaign due to lung cancer
really believing in the American process
and we told you all along
that it was rigged and so this is really
a big deal to have Donna Brazile someone
who has been connected not just to the
Clinton establishment but to the
Democrat Party for over 30 years that
has come out and spilled the tea on her
own friends so I look forward to see
what else is gonna come out as a result
of this scandal she said she never would
have taken the job had she known that
this was all happening an amazing
statement all right before we get to
Doug let me go to Gregg Jarrett Gregg
you know when you put together all of
these separate issues and all of them
you've got this particular case you've
got uranium one you got the email server
scandal you I mean it's like a scandal a
second a day here with them